business day special on tap rubber game
of a three game set and pressure on that
guy
jeff hoffman gets the ball against the
mets making his return
from the injured list and obviously so
glad to be back
one loop to left
jog in for jesse winker
and jeff hoffman after a lead off walk
sets him down one two three
marcus strowman will try and get the
rubber game for the mets this afternoon
what's going to be interesting to watch
for strowman to see his toyota numbers
he hasn't gone more than five innings in
his last four starts but even more
importantly
his slider usage in its last four or
five starts
has gone from 21 or so all the way down
to 13
and that was a pitch that batters were
batting
200 or a little less than 200 on
2-1 to winker with tyler stevenson on
deck
and wicker bounces one strowman off the
mound good throw to second and the turn
by guillerme for the one six
three double play strowman's won a gold
glove and
he gets off the mound as quick as any
pitcher in the game
so one hadn't that jonathan vr is
playing third base today
that's lifted out to right center field
back goes aquino at the wall and it's
out of here
there's the left-handed power jonathan
vr with his 10th home run of the year
his seventh as a left-hand batter
the mets have a one-nothing lead and uh
apparently we're going to get a review
of that i don't know why
it was not even close well the guy who
lost the phone
needs it when he goes to the verizon
store as proof that
his phone was hit by a home run well
brian gorman and larry vanover are the
crew chiefs in the
replay bunker and i don't know what
they're reviewing it's clearly a home
run it was over the yellow line it was
off the guy's phone and it should take
about 10 seconds to review this tops
he wasn't standing up he wasn't reaching
over
and it's going to be a quick one so
there you go
home run confirmed
check swing and he went around strike
three that was a tough one by vic
you're kidding me says joey do you know
who i am i'm joey votto from mississippi
ontario that's a terrible come on
that cara paz are from long island by
the way two balls two strikes the pitch
that's right down the middle strike
three called marcus stroman
floated a slider right down the center
of the plate rose suarez
struck out a lot the second most of the
national league to win the inning one
two three for strowman two strikeouts in
the inning
and after two it's the manchester one
the reds nothing
that's ripped into left field to base it
for alonso hits so hard they're gonna
have to hold nemo at third
as wicker gets it in so three straight
base hits and that was an absolute
seed off the bound of alonso to load the
bases with nobody out
so pete's now hitting all six games on
this road trip so the mets with a chance
to
extend their lead up one nothing in the
third 3 33 bases loaded two doubles this
year
does have a granny sophie dominic you
got to be ready for his pitch
back and he's ready first pitch but he
flies it out to deep left field that
goes winker near the wall
and it's out of here dom smith with an
opposite field grand
slam second career grand slam for dom is
11th home run of the year and it's five
to nothing new york
[Applause]
aquino rockets that one to left field
tom smith spin and throw hard single by
aquino
rolls on through against the grain of
the shift
hoffman strands a pair
[Applause]
the o2 from strowman and he hits it
right
into the shift mcneal to a knee grabs it
to alonso and an easy one two three
inning for marcus stroman all ground
balls and the grounders are starting to
come and
strowman has retired six in a row
it's lined to right by neato it's going
to go to the gap and get by aquino and
go to the wall
anito digging for second he better hurry
and he
just made it safely he had to turn on
the jets at the end
as naquin who's got a great arm
retrieved that ball
and nearly threw nito out that's five
reds nothing in the fifth
here's guillermo who's one for two
and luis lines that to right center
field deep back goes aquino
and it's out of here luis guillory with
his first home run of the season
a two-run shot to open up a seven to
nothing med
lead
and he's down on strikes for the second
time today
third strikeout for strowman
castianos has been so good strowman
takes care of aquino with dispatch
one two three inning for marcus is
retired nine straight
swing and a miss high heat doo little
downs vr
two two coming and he struck him out
with the slider
strowman retired 12 in a row now
great outing for marcus he's up 7-0
suarez
[Applause]
strollman stranded see if the reds can
solve that riddle
and get to the mets starter
whoa strollman somehow knocked that down
that is an athletic play by marcus
strowman
most pitchers that ball is by him and
into center field but
mark is able to get the glove on and to
make the play turn a double play on
winker
in his winkers first that bad and now
robson of a base hit maybe not that
probably right at the shortstop
it doesn't matter fine play
that's why they hand out the gold watch
how quick that left hand gets down there
to get that ball in the leather
quickness to it underhand toss
and he lifts one out to right well hit
toward the corner conforto over makes
the catch
terrific play by conforto heading toward
that foul corner
just reached out and plucked it before
he got there
it was a fair ball two out well we saw
this from stevenson remember in last
night's game with the sacrifice fly
so he's got some power to right field
but conforto who's been
excellent defensively
[Music]
[Applause]
farmer on the backhand makes the play
tremendous effort but getting the
opportunity to play
and farm it's just been fantastic being
able to throw from different
positions but yeah he's struggling
physically but he has not come out of
that lineup
and has been nails for this team
[Music]
and that's it at the knees strike three
calls down looking
for the second time the third time he's
struck out suarez
good slider by strowman and he's got
back-to-back strikeouts to start at the
bottom of the eighth
this will be strowman's 90th pitch of
the day
and farmer punches one to center field
nimmo coming on to make the catch
side retired strowman threw eight with a
shutout intact
90 pitches under his belt and a 7-0 lead
well marcus strowman was exactly what
the doctor ordered for the man's
pitching staff today
you know he had everything working gary
the sinker the slider
uh the split finger change regular
change he threw a couple times
also but the fish were biting for
the cincinnati reds today and he just
made quick work of them
over eight shutout innings
[Applause]
on the outside corner he got him with
the slider familia strikes off the side
of the ninth
and the mitts with a combined one-hit
shutout